welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of ms
marvel episode 6 the finale which
establishes the mcu kamala khan is a
mutant
with kevin feige erasing in humans
faster than wanted to the mouth of their
king from major marvel proclamations to
twisty post-credit huhs to this
episode's astute attention to detail
with mcu timeline logic i am gonna break
down everything you missed this episode
and explain it all without a home alone
chalkboard the episode opens back in
jersey city agent dieber says this is
what happens when the wrong people get
powers
wrong people kids agent barry another
micro aggression from diver but in this
case toward youths kids having powers is
a bit of a new trend in the mcu these
days the young avengers team up is
imminent also all this talk of
government crackdown on superheroes does
remind us a lot of uh you know mutant
registration and that too is the era we
are now in bruno helps comrade on the
subway so we're gonna transfer the next
stop and head of state okay upstate from
new york you know what else is upstate
new york uh westchester a pretty good
place for a mutant to run away to now we
don't know yet if cameron is a mutant as
well if he can harness his nor light the
same way kamala can maybe over the
opening credits is a 2018 track by
artist janubi kurosh called captain
space it's titled a nod to captain
marvel who swaps places with kamala in
the post-credits scene likely connected
to this captain's link to the space
stone and cre-tech like the nega bands
which is what it looks like the bengals
are we see the statue of liberty
inexplicably green once more even though
spider-man no way home showed how it was
being restored to its brown copper color
and no way home takes place before ms
marvel this episode was deliberate about
setting itself in 2025 so i don't know
what's going on here but when i saw the
statue of liberty in the no way home
trailer remember i was like
x-men 2000 reference mutants are coming
so i don't know i choose to interpret
this as ms marvel showing me the statue
of liberty in the title that does
actually end with the proclamation of
mutants in the mcu as a nod to the
famous climax of that 2000 film a symbol
of arrival to a new world both the
immigrants of the khan family and we
could paraphrase that poem as give me
your tired your poor your hud old
mutants longing to breathe free kamala
reveals her powers to her family but
they all already know a little detail
from the g willa wilson's comics taisha
asks are your powers limitless or do you
have to recharge oh yeah kamala doesn't
get to answer but this could be a nod to
how in the dc comics green lantern has
to recharge the ms marvel titles take us
back to jersey city we see police tape
then a blueprint then kamala's
hand-drawn puppets from her video in
episode 1 then imprinted on her high
school hoodie established 2014 referring
to kamala khan's solo series published
in 2014 initially then in neon over the
circle q store before it exploded then
on the school bus then on an arm cast
cause you know bruno's arm is in a cast
right now and then on a digitized screen
of an old game boy or maybe a ti-83
calculator then on a jersey city police
squad car then on a train station
destination board karachi is actually
listed right above it then the neon
outlines from kamala's fantasy with
komron back in episode 2 they're
surrounded here by halal food carts
riding a hot dog past a ferris wheel
with hamburgers on it then written a
street paint then painted on that
graffiti wall among her in bruno's
cosplay pitches back from episode one i
like how all the avengers by the way
depicted there are ones adjacent to his
marvel on the phase four lineup
including doctor strange black panther
and captain marvel and then lastly her
pure nor form signalling the completion
of kamala's evolution on this show
manima gives kamala her own new suit in
a milk toppings box this is what sana
mailed the bangle to her end and we
learned in episode four sonic kept these
boxes around her home in karachi and the
women of this family bonded over eating
these muniba began this season stitching
kamala an avenger costume that kamala
did not want but now miniva makes one
unique for kamala that she needs using
elements from kamala's journey the
embroidery if you notice takes the form
of interlocking blue cubes evoking the
tesseract the cosmic tech that gave
carol danvers her powers kamala lily
pads across her nor disc set to chai's
light switch the lyric being i want to
see the light with no light switch as
kamala learns this episode that her
ability to manifest her light doesn't
necessarily need the switch of her
bangle the bengal just kind of unlocked
it now if the euro king returns a qr
code appears in his truck if you scan it
this week it's been updated to issue
number 19 of g willow wilson's miss
marvel last day's arc which ends with
bruno confessing his love for kamala but
kamala telling them she doesn't have
room in her heart for a thing with him
right now this episode ends with bruno
leaving a letter for kamala and we have
no idea what it said or if she even read
it also my favorite easter egg this
episode nashaf's a sanitation grade is
actually dated march 14 2025 attention
to detail proving this show is actually
trying to take seriously the mcu
timeline as this show would be set in
spring 2025 after hawkeye was in
christmas 2024. thank you to betterhelp
for sponsoring this video if you think
he might be feeling depressed stressed
anxious or overwhelmed betterhelp is
here to help better help offers licensed
therapists who are trained to listen and
help you message your therapist in a
private online environment at your
convenience there's a broad range of
expertise and better helps over 20 000
therapists network that gives you access
to help that may not be available in
your area you just fill out a
questionnaire to help assess your
specific needs and then you get matched
with the therapist in under 48 hours
then you schedule secure video and phone
sessions plus you can exchange unlimited
messages and everything you share is
completely confidential you can request
a new therapist at no additional charge
anytime join the 2 million plus people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with an experienced better health
therapist get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com new rockstars or click
the link in the description that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash new rockstars for ten
percent off your first month in the
mosque notice how someone put their
fancy shoes on the highest guppy hole on
that wall probably to keep that short
little shoe thief from snatching them
also on top of the shelving unit some
boxes block the hidden door that we see
later this is where nakia and the sheik
and the moss bro hide the two of them
but diva returns to the mosque and still
refuses to take her shoes off while
walking out on that prayer floor so rude
no cookies for dieber nakia tries to
block diver um
it's
holy whoa one of the ages totally just
shoulder checked ever she seems pretty
isolated among her fellow dodc
investigators the dodc ain't all bad the
she gives bruno and comrade the
disguises of ball caps haram and halal
the words for forbidden and permissible
this is keeping up with the running mcu
gag of using mere ball caps as disguises
starting in captain america winter
soldier and then mocked and ant-man the
wasp relax no one's gonna recognize us
what because of hats and sunglasses
it's not a disguise hank we look like
ourselves at a baseball game and in
captain marvel does uh announcing your
identity on clothing help with the
covert part of your job comrades nor
spasms
yeah a little detail i like how kamala's
noir lights up on her hands
instinctively as she covers her ears and
has cameron screams we can hear nachva's
voice calling out to him this would
suggest that nashville might not be
fully dead that either her soul lives on
as this nor maybe when her earthbound
corporeal body eroded into a skeleton
her actual consciousness in her soul
transferred to the nord dimension where
it now resides and is continuing to
puppet komron to try to carry out our
evil plot to merge the nord dimension
into this one when kamala calls kareem
he is examining his map that waleed uses
to show the outline of the nora realm
now the magnifying lens is fixed on the
border between india and pakistan like
korea might be seen if the recent veil
incident might have changed the border
between realms and we find out that the
red daggers just have random boats men
at the new jersey harbor ready to go at
notice whenever and secret easy to
navigate underground tunnels to get
there
throughout the school the posters
include if you see trash throw it away
and then stones of diversity build a
path to peace and then a comic book club
nice and then another one for dust and
berry for president a nod to the set
crew member dustin berry on the show
nakia joins them along with zoe zimmer
what are you doing here the theater has
good lighting it's where i film my tech
talks remember in episode 2 kamala and
bruno tested out her powers backstage at
the theater which might be how zoe
figured out kamala was her hero their
plan involves them swiping hoodies from
lockers and a skeleton from a science
lab notice how brutal just goofs around
in the background dancing with one bruno
mistress death phase four hook up
confirmed and these chemicals the
chalkboard actually lists hydrogen
peroxide dry yeast warm water and liquid
disc show which actually are the
ingredients for that elephant toothpaste
bone that you see in youtube videos the
dod soldiers arm their sonic cannons
now remember these are stark tech the
repulsors he designed for the army to
use on hulk in the 2008 film and then
later installed in war machines armor
and civil war and in the drones in far
from home actually since the dodc now
owns those drones they may have reverse
engineered those repulsors from the
drones themselves and here notice how
they charge by using the same charge
sound effect that iron man's technology
uses
nakia and zoe load some softballs
together i think kamal should be able to
tell the world when she's ready
yeah this is a little not to zoe
situation in the comics zoe later
reveals a major crush on nakia zoe
herself is definitely waiting to tell
the world when she is ready the dodc
agents bust in to find bruno's ai amazon
alexa knockoff zuzu which plays coco
karina from the 1966 ernie film armon
sung by ahmed rushdie it's considered
the first real pop song of pakistan the
fact that they cut it off by blasting
zuzu is criminal zoe goes live on tick
tok where the comments include hang on
help is coming
help zoe everyone in jersey city get to
chs avengers go to kohl's high so needs
you on the wayzo hashtag popcorn popcorn
backup coming zoe squad on i-78 we
helping our girl stop commenting go to
chs now and then popcorn popcorn
remember is a callback to zoey's low
calorie video that cleary really loves
popcorn popcorn
their plan involves them confusing the
dodc agents by disguising themselves all
in the same red hoodies and hats a trick
that we actually saw in the 1999 remake
of the thomas crown affair and in my
favorite episode of nathan for you
outside barry asks if he can multiply
now a nod to the marvel mutant multiple
man not that mutant berry so they set up
one of the skeletons to stab a knight
into a balloon that pops the ingredients
together to make the foam now notice
they dressed up the skeleton to look
like norman bates's mother from psycho
they put a wig on it and they also put a
face and hair on the balloon it makes no
sense how many steps they added to this
but i love it come on cameron hide in
this office this is actually mr wilson's
guidance counselor office now remember
comrade interrupted kamala and bruno's
kiss of the wedding and now bruno
returns a favor to be the cob
uh
christmas bruno distracts the soldiers
you know you like these moves
hey guys what's going on
you know this is actually what happens
whenever i try to dance government
soldiers should come in and hit me in
the face but notice how it looks like
bruno is doing the same moves that he
learned for the wedding dance nakia
bikes into the gymnasium where the
volleyball state champion banners also
adhere to accurate mcu timeline logic
2024 would have been the most recent
season earlier that fall they also won
in 2022 2019 and 2012 2019 2022 would
have meant that they won two
championships during the blitz i assume
all the other volleyball teams were just
very depressed in the bathroom there is
a poster for the hero volunteer club no
powers no problem every bit counts i
mean i mean it kind of counts every kid
who didn't have powers in the school got
arrested cameron figures out his mother
is dead
she tried to destroy everything
she was trying to save all women yeah
there's that national music sting again
and as cameron steps out to attack the
dodc the sting plays for him as well
and then every time he does something
really bad it kind of seems like najma's
disembodied soul is kind of possessing
kamran in this episode cameron uses his
nor for hostile attacks while kamala
used her powers defensively she forms a
shield to protect both of them but dever
wipes it out with the big sonic cannon
just like the trunk mounted one in the
2008 hulk film but then kamala says it
yes the magic word for the comics that
we have been waiting for because this is
what kamala is supposed to do she's
supposed to embiggen in this case it is
the nor stretching out her limbs and we
see a slightly scaled up version of
kamala and i love how this pays off the
references throughout the series to
ant-man her various doodles the mural in
karachi her comparing herself in episode
2 to ant-man's eternal youth our girl
finally ambigans now the quick editing
suggests they might have had a limited
vfx budget to show this on screen for
too long and really few shots give us a
sense of her actual scale but there is
one quick cut as kimron flips over the
truck of the crowd wide shot shows her
to be about 10 feet tall and this hero
shot of kamala with her and big and
fists is the angle of her love and
thunder uses when they added her to that
movie's marvel studios title card kamala
encases them both in a dome of their own
nor so they can have their heart to
heart now while the series retcons
kamala as a mutant instead of an inhuman
i like to think that this dome does at
least represent a terrigen cocoon for
them at least metaphorically both of
them emerging from it transformed
kamala's transformation to her final
form is really the final layer of her
suit armor her jersey city community
forming a human shield including the
jcpd all of whom have her back and as
she flees off into the night sky the
overhead shot of the crowd cheering
noticed bruno at the center of it all
just sadly pumping his fist he's like
yeah caltech it is for me then a tick
tock montage showing paul from episode
two reenacting kamala's moves like that
star wars kid mean notice how his name
is master paul 616 a nod to the 616
universe which this mcu is now
designated as of doctor strange's
multiverse menace we also see the sheik
who later becomes a hot dog filter and
then the euro king najaf and the mosque
bro and mr wilson aka gw not the bridge
proving that he was the guy defending
night light on tick tock in episode
three then auntie ruby and then this
account she looks so familiar yes the
real gw is a cameo by g willow wilson
the actual comics writer behind the 2014
series that this is all based on then it
ends with this little jerking action
superhero mad skills yes homie dizzle is
the shoe thief who kamala saved in
episode two his caption of course is ice
cream pizza for life because he loves it
we get this moment where kamala
nervously takes in her own reflection
and strikes her comics posed this book
ending kamala's awkward adjustments to
her cosplay in front of the mirror back
in episode one back then she was a
pretender now she is the real deal yusuf
tells his daughter and if you saved one
life
well
you saved the world
yes this is a verse from the quran
whoever saves the life it is as though
he had saved the lives of all mankind in
this case saving kamran literally saved
this realm from destruction and if you
remember back to the first iron man
jensen and tony stark time proved that
by saving tony stark he saved everything
in reality yusuf reveals that they named
her kamala because kamal means perfect
in arabic while in urdu it is closer to
wonder or marvel making her their little
miss marvel so if you think about it her
mother gave kamala the suit that was
made from gifts from walid and kareem
with a sigil from her necklace that had
her own name in urdu her grandmother
provided the bangle bruno provided the
mask and now her father provides the
name miss marvel and i just love the
shot of yusuf watching her go
magic
absolute magic we see her leaping away
reflected in the lenses of his glasses
and kamala sits on the lamplight looking
across the river at manhattan the red
scarf in the breeze recreated directly
from the cover of miss marvel number
five and i always just love how this
image frames kamala as a jersey city
hero not rumbling with the bigger names
in the city but opting to protect her
home neighborhood on this side of the
river one week later bruno shows up
wearing a shirt reading either gigawatt
or gigawatt either way a nod to his past
marty mcfly look and explains why the
bengal in the nor empowered kamala but
not the others of her family making the
boldest declaration we have heard in the
mcu in quite some time kamala there's
something different
in your genes
like
like a mutation
whatever it is it's just gonna be
another label holy [ __ ] yes that was ron
wasserman's 90s x-men animated theme
which we also heard when charles xavier
floated in and multiverse of madness
yes folks kamala khan in the mcu is a
mutant this is the first 616 character
defined as such in the mcu and hearing
the word mutation is such a huge deal
now making kamala khan a mutant is a
retcon from the comics where kamala is
an inhuman now just a bit of background
on the inhumans the inhumans were really
established in 1965 in the 80s marvel
kind of backburnered them as the x-men
really became the dominant title of the
brand until 1998 when a really great
award-winning series by paul jenkins
revitalized the inhumans and then in the
2000s when marvel studios began
producing films and tv marvel ceo ike
perlmutter overseeing a different
division of marvel like the merch and
the toys separate from kevin feige
promoter temporarily halted new x-men
comics from being written to instead
focus on titles like inhumans why to
give the company a way to produce
mutant-esque movies and tv shows without
having to go through fox because fox
owned the x-men so basically promoter
was like stop doing x-men comics we
don't want to help out a rival studio
which is a real bummer because in
previous decades new marvel heroes would
get introduced and just be casually
established as mutants but kamala khan
got her powers by breathing terrigen
mist and entering a cocoon and coming
out with stretchy powers categorized as
an inhuman so we could look at this as
kevin feige just restoring kamala khan
to what she probably would have been if
not for perlmutter's weird business
decision then again fans of the inhumans
and the ways the inhumans were explored
in the abc series and agents of shield
might see this as inhuman erasure and i
totally hear them but as much as i
really love inhuman characters like
black bolt and quake i don't need kamala
khan to be an inhuman as well and black
bolt being in multiverse of madness
means that inhumans exist throughout the
multiverse including this one most
likely and kamala being a mutant opens
up other doors for the mcu remember at
comic con of 2019 kevin feige did
promise that mutants were coming but he
did not say x-men necessarily just
mutants and now we learned this is what
he meant mutants of course include the
x-men but also the mutant brotherhood
the runaways deadpool namor is
technically marvel's first mutant and
we're gonna meet that guy in black
panther wakanda forever and do not be
surprised if they call him a mutant in
that movie and of course wanda maximoff
and her sons are also often considered
mutants mutants all share the mutant
gene or the x gene it occurs randomly
throughout the population and can get
triggered by puberty trauma or energy
exposure or some other kind of stimulus
in kamala's case it was the bangle
kamala's bloodline came from the nord
dimension but no one else in her family
had powers even with the bangle only
kamala because of her unique mutant gene
activated by the bangle that allows her
to draw power from her ancestral
dimension yes it's a little confusing
yes it might have made more sense just
to make her an inhuman but oh well now i
get mutants and along with kamala many
more individuals will soon be
established to have a mutant gene as
well maybe some who have always been
here just outside of our view like in
616 magneto could have still had an
origin in world war ii we just haven't
seen it yet other mutants may arrive
into 616 from another universe via an
incursion like how 838 had patrick
stewart as professor x and ryan reynolds
deadpool is confirmed to join the mcu
with secret wars on the horizon any
number of beloved x-men actors could
join the mcu as well look folks we're
going to be discussing the mutants a lot
more in future videos this was a seismic
game changer and i am stoked nakia says
get in loses we're getting shawarma both
a nod to the avengers favorite post
battle snack and the line for mean girls
getting loser we're going shopping the
closing credits merge imagery from
jersey city and karachi showing how both
sides of kamala's worlds are now united
then on to the post-credits scene where
kamala's bengal glows a new color and
her body twists into ribbon and then she
wakes up as captain marvel carol danvers
brie larson making a cameo while at
first this reads like a nod to kamala's
initial transformation as she left the
terrigen cocoon into a doppelganger of
her hero captain marvel in the comics
really what happened here was kamala and
carol swapped places because she doesn't
look at her own body in the mirror
confused she just kind of looks around
her surroundings confused where she is
but notice how carol's suit is updated
whereas before it was blue on top and
red in the midsection and legs now it is
red on top and blue everywhere else down
to blue boots it actually looks more
similar to her 90s look at the end of
the captain marvel film she also does
not wear the full red gauntlet length
gloves her forearms are bare now with
shorter wrist length fingerless gloves
also notice kamala's teleportation just
looks different than you'd expect her
body twists into ribbony putty we
haven't seen this kind of production
design in the mcu there's no glowing
portal thank god it's a whole new design
meaning a completely new form of
technology and magic is unfolding before
our eyes and in marvel comics when
characters like nightcrawler teleport
they're actually traveling through the
medium of another dimension in between
those points for nightcrawler it's the
brimstone dimension here i think it is
teleportation through the negative zone
because i think the bengal is alien cree
technology based on the cree mega bans
from captain marvel comics in those
comics and mega bands were given to
captain marvel by the cree supreme
intelligence and trapped him in the
negative zone meanwhile on earth former
avenger rick jones uses these bands
clinks them together to trade places
with captain marvel just like these two
women are swapping places so i think
carol was in possession of the other
bangle the long lost one assuming these
bengals are creetech and that the ten
rings are creetech the pulsing beacon of
the ten rings could have been summoning
the kree empire to earth to acquire the
second bangle meanwhile carol found one
of these bangles and in this moment
spatially swapped places with kamala and
the reason carol says oh no no no is
that maybe she was in the negative zone
in that moment and now she knows she is
now cosmically handcuffed to some poor
girl who loves her but now she doomed
that girl to a frightening dimension
setting all this up for the marvels next
summer and since kamala is now a mutant
who knows maybe it makes it likelier
that rogue will appear in that movie and
drain carol's powers but i used the word
doomed and that was no accident my
friends because i think doom is going to
play a very big part in all this the
multiverse of madness producers just
confirmed that they designed reed
richards portal on the technology of
viktor von doom's time platform i think
the mcu may be bracing to introduce doom
so there you have it folks mutants time
travel the negative zone teleportation
the 10 rings alternate dimensions the
dodc magic scotland's podcast and then
all that wrapped together in a hug of
wholesome family coming of age vibes
with a killer soundtrack i loved this
show thank you for joining me on these
breakdowns of it follow me on instagram
and twitter at hey boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you